You can also respond to user
interaction with your street-view,
and there's some great methods for
doing this.
First of all, you can detect whenever
the camera changes by looking
at a new direction or zooming in and
out with a handler called
setOnStreetViewPanoramaCameraChangeList-
ener.
If your user touches on the panorama and
you want to detect
that to respond to it, you can use to
set OnStreetViewPanoramaClickListener.
If the panorama changes, typically by
the user navigating to a new location,
you can also detect this using the
setOnStreetViewPanoramaChangeListener.
These are all very useful if you
want to build an app that provides
information about the location
that you're looking at.
For example, in the Grand Canyon Hike,
it would be really cool if you could
show the direction the user is facing in
as they pan around to look at the canyon
for various spots on the trail or plot
on a map where they are on the trail.
See if you can figure out
how to do this for yourself.
It's beyond the scope of what
you're learning here, but
it might be useful for
your final application.